I can't help but notice whenever I see
these viral Clips go around of some Pro
sex work person or some Pro only fans
person or some show for the porn
industry will come out there's very
often demonic devilish imagery that goes
along with that horns and Tails and
pitchforks well yeah Las Vegas is Sin
City how come it's always these same
images and these same symbols all of
which have been considered demonic and
occult for thousands of years does that
feature into porn or no I mean I would
just point it yeah I know the fur like
the Deep symbolism that points directly
to evil but to your point yes it is a
direct correlation of evil where God is
absent there is there is only evil to
the person advocating for the porn
industry saying well how else could this
person provide for their family they had
to do that this is their right who in
their right mind wants to be a
prostitute yeah like no one wants that
yeah it's just a lie